I know much I may have made a terrible
mistake but I look hot today we're
trying heels we are gonna be going
through the gauntlet the high heels
gauntlets
going to dinner going to bars go and
dance and we're gonna wear heels the
whole time we're having ourselves a
night what advice do you have for us
don't
I love Isles I think they look fabulous
on women I think with a pretty damn good
on men it totally is hot right heels are
like a fun fancy thing you get to do
when you go out I [ __ ] hate heels
I'm a shorter man and when girls wear
heels around me it makes me shorter I
shrink it they get taller and I get
shorter you pop on four extra inches
guess what I can't compete with that
all right let's try on these torture
devices I feel like the best part is
actually even before I go out and I'm
like yeah I look good I'm wearing ankle
boots they have a zipper along the side
I actually think they're really cute I
don't know that I can put this on I
would have to sit I'm just trying to get
home without a broken ankle okay not so
bad I would wear this yeah pineapples I
have one that's not stilettos wide wide
base who's that man walking down the
street with those delicate feet its deck
for tonight I wanted to show off a lot
of my foot my fiance painted my toenails
I have chosen a little black strappy
heel I've never had a buckle some tiny
three inches tall oh you can only see
four of my toes why did I paint all 10
of my toes if you can only see about
seven I would wear this to an
eighth-grade dance
I feel pretty [ __ ] hot when we did
the drag video I had on boot heels
that doesn't count so tonight I'm gonna
wear stilettos for the first time I get
flat forms or wedges there's nothing
else okay okay would you be the
and give me a shoulder the horse yes
thank you this is meds he'll a four inch
silver sandal that looks it looks like
it came straight out of my closet ten
years ago but doesn't make my butt look
good if ariel does decide to wear heels
i set a timer three hours later I either
have to sit down or I have to go home I
don't think that's gonna last more than
an hour oh man I don't like Christmas
but I do like unwrapping still have high
heels for me are just a part of fashion
my heels for tonight are actually called
dagger pumps because the stiletto is so
tall no [ __ ] kill you yeah I
can't even stand on my toes as high as
these oh [ __ ]
maybe this isn't mistake air hole that's
upsetting I don't think I've ever seen
the shoe that bit this is Lady gaga
where would I see these I'd see this is
a show where would I wear these I
wouldn't what do you think is gonna
happen they're [ __ ] daggers
[Music]
bring band-aids spring flats instead of
tapping out we're going to be flatting
out and that's when you decide to put on
your flats Eugene he's already started
to damage the barbra the Tigers strike
let's [ __ ] tonight up
[Music]
we leave my house and immediately I
realized that walking is nearly
impossible even just in getting from
Eugene's house to the restaurant a lot
of us are getting cranky already that is
just like the Henry estai vebber seen
him getting very we actually get out and
I'm like this is not practical first we
go to dinner dinner is sitting sittings
great having fun
you've got [ __ ] two entrees I was
hungry you can't tell me what to eat
when I'm wearing heels it's not the
horse yet the worst part of wearing
heels is actually walking in between
places there's no seats while you're
walking down a sidewalk in our first bar
super close right just had to cross the
street it was like maybe half a block it
took us nine minutes to get there I mean
it's basically like watching toddlers on
ice skates right we get to this steep
incline where the sidewalk goes to the
road it's just so steep who decides
these specific sidewalks there's a lot
of uneven terrain but we're at the first
bar time to partay the best thing is
when you walk in for the first 10
minutes you feel incredible that you
feel like you look incredible as much as
this hurt I recognize that when I stood
in those six-inch stilettos I looked
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] but I'm getting hit
on like crazy I'm so much taller than
normal yeah it was fun oh I love the
attention it's a great 10 to 15 minutes
[Music]
now and very soon we're all sat at a
table Ned blinked both of his heels on
the stool and then as he stood up to
bleep Momentum's going forward but my
heels are stuck on the stool and I just
go see me [ __ ] face planted like
Bambi but the bartender is like calling
my drinks back thinking that I need to
be cut off
nope not wasted just wearing heels we
are now done with the first part we are
heading to the second bar Ariel is doing
something for me which I always do for
her my biggest nuisance has always been
that we are walking fast enough nuisance
you never walk this way
I look good I feel good I'm taller that
shoes are the back cause you have a
protective layer all in clothes
Metin Keith however are at risk for
being stepped on because their toes are
exposed and they're low to the ground
somebody bumped into me and stepped on
my toe he said welcome to the real world
oh we get to the next bar I'm looking
hot and my friends are [ __ ] sitting
down I'm dancing that's my game the
heels are not hurting me yet but I'm a
forward-thinking man I'm responsible so
I'm gonna get drunk when you drink it
distracts you from the pain there's a
pool table and if anybody knows anything
about pool it's all about bending over
and sticking out that to pop that booty
oh you got heels that tush is got the
push the drinks are hitting and that
means is time to dance dancing usually
happens towards the end of the night
Eugene starts not only dancing but
getting down harder than I have ever
seen a man get down in my life there's a
weird feeling that in the heels I wanted
to impress people more so when I was
challenged to dance I'm gonna [ __ ]
danced wearing literally daggers and it
did not feel good I'm taking the tiniest
little steps I've ever taken in my life
honestly the worst thing about wearing
heels out for a long time is feeling
like a burden and so I try to grit my
teeth and bear it which means that my
toes bleed I turn around and half of the
group is gone Keitha Ned are dying
my feet hurt I'm done with this I go
outside I stand by a dumpster and I take
off my heels oh man oh that feels okay
the look on his face was just pure bliss
its bugged those things they hurt at
this point I've fallen over I've gotten
stepped on I've gotten catcalled
and honestly my night is over
you're on the dirty ground my fear on
the dirty ground but I don't care my
toad you're like ah it's like all your
stress is gone except my feet still hurt
we should grab those shoes though they
were expensive the final walk we had to
make was between the third and fourth
bar after Keith and Nedley
alright how was it it's just not even
funny anymore Eugene at this point is
dying I wanted to take my stiletto off
and stab myself repeatedly in the brain
every single person and surface around
me is just something that could
stabilize me from falling over
almost got hit by a car that was super
chill friends won't wait for me car
please [ __ ] people we get to the last
bar I'm dancing but we're not having fun
anymore the heels take a physical toll
and the physical toll takes a mental
toll every inch of my being was
screaming get out of these heels it is
clear to me at this point the Eugene
might be doing severe and permanent
damage to his feet I didn't take it off
because I was gonna last through the
night so that my sisters my mom would be
proud
I'm
six inches is asking a lot of someone's
feet the heels come off let me get to
walk home barefoot normally I'm carrying
my friend's home who take off their
heels tonight
Zach carried me home I really understand
why someone in heels is done with
partying after two or three bars it's
just another question of fashion versus
function do you value looking super
crazy sexy I actually kind of liked it I
liked being a little taller it added
confidence or do you also value having a
comfortable night out my wife has a
timer for a reason
I had a timer tonight too I think most
important we're within that spectrum and
it's your choice to decide where you
want to be the metaphor is you won't
understand until you walk a mile in
their shoes it's right thanks for
watching we're the try guys and we have
a brand new show called squad worse it's
on YouTube red so it's basically try
guides with celebrities and more
explosions you get a purse RDAs for free
if you wait till March ago it's the
whole thing and pay nothing that what's
in this video and watch that video get
out here
[Music]
I woke up this morning with insane
amount of pain so when I look down my
right foot is still [ __ ] bleeding
really [ __ ] awful
just the worst but I love God